the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and is using us
instead of us using it but with the
adana you can use it in perfect
alignment with your life the adan app is
already used by 40 million believers
around the world why because it caters
to your islamic lifestyle on top of this
a lot of times you get the
the islamic calendar ramadan calendar
suhur and iftar times
hajj and umrah guide qibla finder
and much more for free so download the
addon up now
assalamu alaikum
and welcome back to this podcast in the
dunya the three muslims today we're
joined in person with a very special
guest
such a blessing such a blessing such a
blessing masha allah through something
to actually be able to do that and not
be on some zoom call phenomenal
phenomenal within itself and it's
honestly just great to just see the vibe
amongst you guys and allah united you
guys you zoom but now allah has
connected
so
today
why don't we just jump right into it
because we were already talking about
this before we got into today's video
and um we were popping off it was
getting real like
real real dense just so you guys know
this was not supposed to be an episode
whatsoever we were just having like a
off-camera thing and we we thought hey
man let's just hit record bro we keep it
unfiltered okay we have to let's go
and you know what i don't know i don't
know how you guys are going to take it
i'll be honest with you i think that
everyone over here is going to benefit
from it and i think that you guys are
going to benefit from it as well too and
inshallah the biggest mistake you can do
is by clicking off this do not click off
this podcast this is a very real podcast
that you're not going to hear from your
local shiok because they don't have
experiences with these things and they
don't have the knowledge when it comes
to that specific things but
alhamdulillah islam has guided us and
kept us in a way that it doesn't allow
us to stray away from the path yeah you
know i mean and all of our past brings
us to who we are right now alhamdulillah
that's the main thing
but listen
before we start this off before i have
have a little summer for you guys i have
a little gift but i have a little gift
what's good for real i do mashallah
you know the prophet muhammad said to
spread uh gifts and give gifts amongst
each other correct
yes it increases love between each other
so i have a little song for you guys
oh bro
no this was not planned i didn't even
know this was
guys i hit it under a towel so you don't
see nothing
like that i saw tyler's like why is it a
towel why is your towel here okay uh bro
this is for you yo
yes a little merch action a little more
attractive first of the batch first of
the batch may allah bless you guys hope
you guys enjoy them the new zems and boy
murders oh my god
no no no
seriously seriously thank you so much
for doing this and you know a lot of
people are starting to see this a lot
more you know for the zamzam boys and
everything that we're doing obviously i
have the non-profit where
um we have the zem zom that we imported
from mecca and
we're doing 100 profits to building
schools in palestine and pakistan we're
just doing a bunch of cool projects
inshaallah um and this is just a way to
further the daoa bro because look you're
in the game you're doing podcasts right
if you want to do an upgrade for your
stuff right you know how expensive it is
right if you want to do something even
cooler you have to wait for a sponsor
and all that sort of stuff by allowing
us to sell our own merchandise we are
now taking control you understand we're
not waiting for example for someone to
offer us a deal you know contracts are
funny one month they're with you two
when they drop you because they're you
know i mean it's just so and so you just
never know what these things so by
allowing people to be a part of
something greater selling this merchant
100 of this merch goes towards our dawa
investment so i get to pay people so my
team members when they come out to times
square street dollar you already know
you know these kids are like 19 years
old right they're the first year of
college second year of college right
they're growing men i cannot
uh continue to hey fisa be left is
they'll do it for the sake of allah they
will but i need to pay them you know i
mean so by the shirt sales and
everything with this i'm able to invest
back into the dawah pay my youth and
just upgrade camera gear and just do fun
stuff and do funner videos without you
know waiting for sponsorships and now we
could scale the channel at such a
massive thing and you guys would be
investors so whoever's buying one of
these shirts which is pretty dope by the
way you gotta admit material feels good
as well too
bro
the logo everything you know i mean and
this is just season one of the drop we
have a lot of cool ideas in charlotte so
a lot more cool merch coming in
everyone's an investor tawa investors
that's what we want we don't want
hand-me-outs it's just darwin messages
links in the description if you want to
support this amazon project yes i highly
recommend you show it i got two
questions for you bro yes number one how
much do you like your jordan's bro i i
you know
this logo looks familiar it does it does
it does right could i get sued from this
potentially but um i don't know i just
thought it looked really cool it was
something familiar and i don't know i
just put it together allah inspired it
to do bro and i don't know it's it's
it's working right it's right
cool
yeah and my second question most
important question bro
sq man are we actually legitimately one
of the first people to wear this yes sir
so beside besides so these are an actual
sample of a t-shirt so before it was a
hoodie the first people to ever wear the
t-shirt is you guys
the first people who are a teacher
not even my team members have worn this
yet they don't even know i have them for
i'm going to give them a surprise later
on
so they're going to get them too uh
they're going to come in multiple
colorways and uh with a different type
of lo like the logo is gonna be here
with different colors and stuff
inshallah so you know stay stay tuned
insha'allah support with the dawah and
you know i mean we're trying to be like
young muslim entrepreneurs like we're
not again we're trying to build
something of our own we're not trying to
again take hand me outs we're not
looking for donations no we want you to
be investors we want you guys to see the
vision and support you know i mean
support this amazing uh podcast support
guys support people who are doing things
that i mean so we don't want hand me
outs we we want people to be investors
and support us inshallah
with this word being said let's move
into
what was actually going on before the
scenes bro
substances psychedelics
all of this stuff we've we've spoken
about it in a few eps but we never spoke
about it with sq and you know there's
obviously a lot of videos of people you
know talking about this but i think
i think we could definitely bring some
value of benefit
um and please understand
we may say some things which
uh it's from it's from the past but it's
all with the intention to help
true please understand this is not a
video to boast or to be like oh wow this
is not a pro
and like you know we're like oh my god i
remember back in the day spiritual
enlightenment you know what it's
actually one of the most frightening
things that you could ever do and i
would never recommend this to anyone and
if someone can learn from our potential
mistake specifically mine don't don't do
it don't dabble in it don't touch it
these are literally the works of the
shaitaan yeah literally the work of the
shaitaan literally and if you are taking
these psychedelics and you start seeing
things there's a reason people you know
and it's not forget us right if you hear
you know people are bro google is
available for everyone you search these
things about dmt and all that they tell
you about these figures that everyone
sees
bro i remember this satanist that i was
almost marrying that's another story
within the song
yes i was about to marry a satanist
right subhanallah and she told me what
are the ways that they contact
contact the shayateen and to get in
these trance-like states is they take
t's bro they take t's
yes bro yes because you know it unlocks
a different type of mind in a different
realm of you bro and she was telling me
of how one of the things that they allow
the gin to they didn't call them a gin
they called it a asparagus
like like they they called their spirit
like a friend they treated like a friend
and they said that this friend of ours
communicates and helps us and it talks
to us and they said that this friend has
a network of other friends and we all
have spirits with us listen to what
they're saying about the korean girls
listen to what they're saying about and
and she's like she was telling me about
it and all that and the whole time i'm
thinking about islam i'm just like yo
like that's exactly what islam teaches
and she was just like to get into these
states you know we take these types of
psychedelic things so do not get it
twisted when you see the ancient travels
of the native americans and stuff like
that they were taking substances they
were taking something to get in this
trance-like state and then they play the
beats they play the drums which is also
another instrument of the shaitaan and
they just get you going get you flowing
and then they do these and the hindus
were doing these um a type of
breathing and yoga it's called tantric
yoga or something like that but they
have to like you know do all these
things to get them in this state bro and
these are really dangerous stuff bro
like this is like works of the shaitan
for sure bro 100 100
man
so yeah with that being said we're gonna
be getting into this uh so the first
thing that i think we should kind of
clarify is
why would everyone even want to take
these things because a lot of people you
know
i actually have people that message me
and they're like should i take
psychedelics should i take um
dmt or something like this
and like the first question i gotta ask
is why like what's what's the old
intention behind it i i get that a lot
too and they're just like i wanna come
closer to allah
i'm like are you praying no but i wanna
come closer to allah so so let me ask
you this robby i'll throw this at you
bro like what was the way that the
messenger of allah came closer to allah
the prophet salam well i mean he has a
prophet allah right he had the angel in
jubrilla
come and deliver revelation and there's
actually one very specific instant in
the life process where he was
um he didn't get any revelation for like
six months or so right so he was really
depressed he was really sad no dream no
revelation nothing the angel jibril ai
didn't even come so um he was really sad
and then the angel jupiter came down and
what did he reveal
right and that
that part of the quran comforted the
prophet salam so if you want to get
close to allah you know how what if i
said oh i'm so close to sq i love him so
much i've never spoken to him day in my
life i don't even know what he sounds
like i don't know what words he uses his
vocabulary nothing
you'd be like you know you don't know
the guy and yeah you're not close to him
but allah spent he has an entire
revelation for us entire book for us
right salah that he prescribed for us
and even the hadith question
he says the most high has said the most
beloved acts of worship to me are those
which are obligatory and then he says
and then the servant continues getting
closer and closer to me with voluntary
acts of good.
and when what happens when uh allah is
pleased with their servant what happens
then allah flees with his servant subhan
allah he actually announces to the
angels you know he tells you
i'm pleased with with someone so fulan
and then the angel jibril i assume he
goes to the rest of the angels he says
you know
allah is pleased with them so i am
pleased with them and you're pleased
with them and then all the angels are
pleasing
and you know subhanallah when even
taking it further allah subhanahu
becomes the sight that the person sees
with right the hands that they strike
with the legs that they move with right
and that's something that just shows us
as well too when you know when you're
saying oh so wait you see allah like
not like that right but you are so
focused that you don't see any
negativity you know i mean you're so
focused on pleasing europe that things
craziness is going to be happening you
know you become like those like the the
companions of the cave right all that
sort of stuff but you're in your bag
you're so mentally strong because you
have the sight of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala right he becomes you know the
ears that you hear with you understand
so like you hear
nothing but positivity people gossiping
backbiting it doesn't even phase you
people you know people are talking smack
about you people are writing negative
comments in the comments ah and it
doesn't matter because you're so focused
on pleasing allah azzawajal that your
mind filters out all the other garbage
and scientifically the ras which is a
system in our brain that is literally a
filter system you're not even able to
tell anything you ever ever had um like
for example like maybe you never notice
a specific car but then you're thinking
about buying a car and then all you see
is that car right it's not because in
the market there's more of those cars
it's your ras it's a system that allah
has designed in our brains that's a
filtration system that allows us to
focus on things right because if we
didn't have that our mind would be going
on overload so now allah becomes the
ears that you hear with so you're only
focusing on positivity whenever there's
negativity not only do you not hear it
you're finding yourself getting out of
those conversations i know it's messing
up my vibe
so pleasing allah is what the messenger
is talking about and this is the
messenger of allah he had knowledge of
everything yeah i mean like that we know
of not obviously of the in mulhoy but he
had knowledge right
okay if he needed guidance right if he
needed some type of comfort right
he could have made dua and allah could
have made a mushroom
right he could have had a truffle or
muffin come out and tell him revelation
go and do this sort of stuff imagine
that right imagine that link with the
prophet muhammad saw some look at what
the christians say about new halem that
he was an alcoholic if you say that he's
an alcoholic how can you trust he's
getting revelation is he getting
revelation or is he drunk which one is
it is he blacking out or is he a
messenger of god which one you know i
mean you can't do that you know i mean
if the prophet of allah if that's how
allah wanted to give him visions and all
that he would have been using that sort
of stuff for the comfort but that's not
what he used it's not what you need
that's what the shaitaan has tricked us
to believe that we need to get closer
yes
that's very true it's very true and if
you go back to the beginning of like a
magic and all this stuff allah actually
sent two angels to teach people how to
do magic and all of that and to test
them and advise them this is from no
it's not from allah and if you do it you
know you will be punished look at that
point that you just made because people
make that the wise naturally growing
why why do we have receptors in our
brain why do we have all this because
it's something that you're not supposed
to do that's like saying what if if pork
is haram why is there a pig because
that's a creation of allah that's the
creation of allah allah is
he creates that's what he does but it's
also created as a test so you don't
touch it you don't use it you get me so
like why shouldn't a person be using it
what's something like you know i mean
like it looks like it's a great thing
you know we have these receptors you
know marijuana and all that why what it
feels good it's illegal societally yeah
yeah bro it's like the forbidden fruit
forbidden fruit that adam
and eve they were told to eat from it
and look at that day from it but why
it's like oh allah created it so why
can't why couldn't they eat from it yeah
well clearly like allah told them not to
and allah says in the quran very clearly
like these substances like you said
previously
in them there is some benefit
yeah but the harm for our weighs up
all right so why would one why would
someone want to get into this like we
said they want to get closer to allah
and
if we didn't clarify that already you
know this is not the way that you get
closer to allah that's it do things
happen when you take this do you have
spiritual experiences
yes
that's undeniable but it i've said this
many times before and i'm sure you'll
agree it's like
it's like this telephone
if you have a question
you pick the telephone up to ask allah
this question
allah gives you the answer you hang up
the telephone as quickly as possible
because you can't handle anything else
it was so much like oh
you closed it you just you put the
telephone down when you take this
substance like a psychedelic or anything
like that what then ends up happening is
you're picking up this telephone
you can't put it down
now you're getting like so much and
you're getting overwhelmed hold on hold
on hold on hold on who's to even say
that on the other side it is allah
damn
bro
we're still speaking metaphorically yeah
obviously obviously right who's to say
bro it's legit i remember when i took it
bro i was hearing voices i was hearing
whispers bro i was hearing whispers and
bro that was not allah but he's not
talking to me when i'm on a substance
like that bro it was something else bro
it was something it's scary bro and
wallahi and you know what subhanallah
when i was having a bad trip you know
the only thing that comforted me was the
quran that was the only thing that i was
scared out of my mind bro because when
you go on these bad trips right you
think it will never be over you think
that it is death or like i'm gonna be
like this forever oh my god like you
start thinking going down the road
it's more it gets worse and worse and
worse and worse for us right but bro it
was the quran i still remember till this
day it was
man that calmed me down well
honest to god honest to god it was
calm me down and i realized that no no
allah i need to get out of this i need
to get out of this allah just get me out
of this and whatever this is whatever
you're giving me right now allah it is
not meant for me to have like if i was
meant to know this i would have known
this and if you want to actually reveal
this and give me this knowledge and
inspire me you're not going to use an
intoxication to do that you know i mean
there's so many jinn and shayateen who
are on the other side in this realm and
if this is a spiritual realm that we're
talking about who are you gonna meet bro
these faces like i remember bro
kaleidoscope vision faces
scary faces like my eyes would close i
would see snakes moving bro that's
freaky that's freaky bro like that's not
cool that's not cool so you know like
when a person wants to encourage you to
do it they're going to tell you about
this experience oh my god you're going
to go outside into all the clouds
you walk with the bare feet and oh my
god it feels fantastic these are things
that you're not meant to do these are
things you're not coming to and you know
who this is who uses this those who are
not muslim they have no idea how to
connect with allah the only way that
they know how to connect with allah is
through these substances the way we
connect to allah is through the quran
and even when you use it there's no
guarantee you're connecting with allah
absolutely
no way
ancient like buddhist practices they
they say this thing be careful or beware
of unearned wisdom
because you're not you're not
spiritually at a level where you're
ready to accept these things and maybe
we'll never be perhaps why that's why
allah mentions you know the jinn they
can see you from where you cannot see
them yeah maybe we weren't meant to see
these and this is facts because from
from what i've researched yeah can jin
interact with us yes can they affect us
and harm us yes if they wanted to they
can appear to us but it's not in us and
in our faculties to have to like unveil
that hijab ourselves it's not because
it's going to do more damage than we
think yeah 100 and when you look at
experiences in general right there's not
just
physical experiences they're spiritual
as well and you can liken them to each
other you know there are some physical
experiences we should not have there are
some physical experiences we should not
have yeah same way likewise this is one
of them by the way yeah oops yeah yeah
so spiritual um experiences there are
some reason i have as well connection
with allah allah spent allah with the
quran with prayer of salah and all that
stuff even doing good right remembering
allah beautiful is to connect with allah
this
i would say if anything you're you're
putting available
you're deviating bro you're deviating
from the purity that allah has created
you with because if you think about
these people who
uh like um like who's to say that hitler
didn't do this and get a vision
he took a bunch of shrooms and he got
this vision that this is what he needs
to do and ajin possessed him because
when you do this you understand bro you
know the messenger of allah is that the
atkar is a shield for the believers you
understand when you take these
substances your shields are down
you get it bro i remember taking an
amount i couldn't even remember who i
was like forget saying
i was melted i did not know
where i am what is uh what does i am
even mean like who am i bro it was scary
and subhanallah like
what shield all shields are down all
your defense mechanisms are down and
guess what happens you're open to the
attacks of the shaitaan so now ajin
possesses you now ajin is with you now
jins are writing contracts to be with
you so now you even come out of it and
you're never the same
something's wrong with you now and now
you keep thinking that i'm seeing things
you keep staring at the walls you're
gonna move again like what's happening
over there and now you're just not the
same and now the world being like yo
something's changed and some people want
to feel like more spirits to awaken no
you've let down your defense mechanisms
those shields are down bro and now you
could be easily be possessed you could
easily be possessed and you won't even
know
you're crazy you're psychotic you have
psychosis
and may allah protect us i mean a lot of
people a lot of people know this too
it's not that they won't know but some
people feel naked bro i literally feel
like i'm just i can't i feel like
there's something there that that whole
defense you're talking about they can
literally feel it as like a palpable
sensation that it's not there anymore
it's just like you're you can just be
flanked from any side you won't even
notice
so it's scary it's it's definitely scary
and you know when we have for example
okay look we're talking about something
really extreme okay you know uh you know
the the three muslims what if calm down
a little bit what if i'm just doing weed
all right calm down i'm not doing no
psilocybin mushrooms over here you gotta
understand these are all psychedelics
you understand even marijuana it's a
form of psychedelic it's not it's not
it's not the highest form but it's a
form of psychedelic right why is it why
is it that if you smoke too much or
especially in the beginning stages of
things like that right a lot of people
new smokers and all that sort of stuff
they'll have this paranoia effect bro if
you ever get that pioneer in fact you
will feel like you're being spied on
you're being watched are you in on it
you you you know you will question the
legitimacy of your own family members
people have been admitted into a
hospital and we haven't even spoke about
the fact that if psychosis and
schizophrenia
mental disorder runs in your family you
are opening the portals to forget the
spiritual stuff right just forget that
for a second right even though you can't
but let's suppose put a pin in that
the actual science of your dna you're
unlocking certain perhaps chromosomes or
perhaps certain cells in your biology
that just you know just trigger you the
same way someone's like uh you know like
premature balding you know it can happen
hey i'm not afraid of this baby this is
how allah has made me i love it my wife
loves it too so don't worry right you
know the same way that it could speed up
that process quickly right you could be
unlocking certain qualities and traits
that were hidden in your dna
but because of the marijuana because of
that psychedelic now you're exposing
yourself to it now again you're not the
same see in people that don't believe
this search it up medically
scientifically it's called gene
expression right these genes are it's
like a switch it's literally a switch
bro and and things in our environment
substances drugs chemicals things they
put in our food even so
they can turn these switches on bro and
when that transcription process starts
to grow you will have things come up
that you didn't even know you had and
you know the person starts talking all
crazy like they're more spiritually like
divine and they understand the world
more differently but they all sound
stupid like you really just sound like
you know like you just sound like you're
some like really wise person and all
that sort of stuff the quran has the
wisdom you break down the quran it's not
even read you're not even ready for that
type of wisdom allah says in surah about
if the whole oceans were to become ink
and the trees were to become pencils
right pens like writing mechanisms right
the wisdom and the words of allah still
wouldn't finish it's a mercy from allah
that he's even made it 114 chapters
think about how much wisdom and
knowledge allah has it's his wit it's
his mercy that he's only made it this
much what could the book really be bro
what could the book really we're not
even capable enough to handle that you
know what i mean but now you want to
talk about oh no you know psychedelics
and all these things want to have it you
know and look we're going to get a nice
i think and this is cool i think there's
going to be a nice a conversation in the
comment section about this where people
are going to share you know there's
going to be on both sides of things you
know and and we want to hear those
comments honestly i think that it's good
it pushes everyone's thinking but you
know wisdom comes from allah yes and
this
those brothers are gonna be there bro
but at the end of the day don't don't
share your things and like don't don't
like share for the sake of boasting
anything bro like if you're trying to
help people okay this is a different
thing bro yeah if you're just trying to
like boast and be like oh who can
outdrink one another who can out smoke
well that's that's a joke that's
embarrassing bro that's not something
that we should be proud of bro yes
um going back to what you just ended up
on i think that's a beautiful tangent to
kind of move into islam
he said the quran is wisdom from allah
right look at surah sin right i think it
summarizes this discussion where we
should go perfectly right
right by the quran and basically in its
wisdom right what's wise
indeed you the prophet is the messenger
upon a straight path which means what
and it goes on tenzin
with the revelation from the most
merciful so on and so forth
means what if you want to be on the
straight path the proper path the path
of the mursalien
follow the quran
if you want the wisdom yes if you want
that knowledge it's the quran yes it's
the quran and again once again and if
you feel like it's not
that shows and exposes the disease in
your heart look i'm not gonna we're not
listen we're not going to
you know molly college you you're like
this is not we're not gonna molly coddle
you like for real like this is no joke
psychedelics mushrooms marijuana and all
these things like that bro like you know
when people come to canada there's all
these signs about cannabis and all that
sort of stuff because i've never been to
a country that's like legalize you know
this strange you know
um
so
like there's gonna be advertisement for
it people are living in these countries
where it's becoming legal so it's
important to have these discussions you
know because people are interested in
their peer pressure their friends it's
available you're curious you see going
back to the point that you made
about the forbidden fruit you know when
when allah told them not to eat it they
obeyed like we're not going to do it but
the shaytan was persistent he beautified
that tree how many billions of trees are
there agenda but why was that one
standing out the most he beautified it
again and again and again and again
until it just became so like i gotta try
this anyone once upon a time ask your
former self you would have said no to
drugs no to merit
for allah like no yeah but then it went
from a stuck for allah to
maybe it's not that just once
right
they call marijuana the the gateway drug
for a reason
because once you expose yourself to that
i wonder what that feeling would be like
i wonder what salvia would taste like i
wonder what you know molly would taste i
wonder what an e-pill would take like
you start thinking about all these other
things because it was the gateway it's
the reason it's called the gateway bro
it's it's called the gate before for a
specific reason because it introduces
you to a side that you've never that
you've never had before yeah honestly uh
true story true story right
not just from the jahlia days right but
this is back when i was like we would
communicate on facebook like r.i.p
facebook like i don't even like go on
that anymore right and we were status
updating and all that sort of stuff what
are we doing this weekend it was all
about getting tagged in the picture if
you got tagged in the picture like once
the day was over and you are all like
hungover the next morning you wake up
first thing you check in to see how many
pictures have you tagged in right and
you don't look the best and certain of
in all certain ones you remember certain
ones you don't remember okay
and i remember we were preparing for
this weekend that's coming up right that
right and you know this is when we were
getting exposed to smoking and once upon
a time i had such a strong stance and
the person who was posting about it had
such a strong stance against marijuana
fully like only like they were horrible
with it like only losers deadbeats they
were like i wouldn't go that far like
that's a terrible like you don't want to
you know do that to a person we
shouldn't name call anyone you know i
mean like everyone has their reasons
their sins everyone has weaknesses and
let's just own our weaknesses you know i
i'm not here to debate with you about
medical reasons and all that sort of i'm
not here to talk about the medical
prayer i'm not here to talk about that
again in it there is good we know that
from the quran but the
harm of it outweighs any of the good
that it has to offer okay
so we were talking about you know like
smoking and all that and i'm thinking
that's what they're doing so they said
something in a comment right and this is
how they have their own lingo the drug
world has its own lingo it has nicknames
and stuff and they were like oh are we
rolling this week right and i you know
i'm thinking yeah are you rolling it up
yeah hell yeah count me in right and
they're like
no right we're talking about rolling on
molly like i'm like
what like how did you go from that to
that like when did that happen you know
and they try to offer me and i'm just
like nah i'm good right i'm good but
that was then until a few more times
later
why not why not try it out you know and
again this is going back to your point
the shaitaan beautifies that forbidden
fruit of your that forbidden tree
until
you know what that's what's the harm
let's you know yeah i'll say for allah
for allah
come on you you're gonna you're going to
pre-meditate a sin
in the world of the dunya when someone
commits a murder or something that's a
premeditated murder you're premeditating
a sin and just saying i'll say it's not
for allah later on it's not for allah to
that bro like that's just that that's
just crazy i don't know yeah 100
why are people getting into this bro in
the first place
aside from like the whole thing because
i know you said the whole curiosity
thing right but a lot of people they
don't realize that they're coping with
something deeper with these crutches
you know like they might actually have
traumatic things without these
they might actually have some stuff in
their childhood yeah some some really
messed up stuff bro yeah and they might
be you know say they're failing grades
their parents really want them to go to
this or it could be anything bro
they distract themselves they don't want
to do the inner work or anything that we
talk about but they do this because they
might look at it as okay maybe they
don't even look at it maybe it's
unconscious or subconscious they're just
like oh what's the harm in it they don't
realize that they're addicted to it you
know so what do you say to these people
bro well they distract themselves and
then on top of that
uh what they are doing is they are
trying to experience
more
well think about what i just said like
oh why why um do people take these
things they want to get closer to allah
right they want to
experience more why would you want to
get close to allah if what you're doing
is not already giving you that
connection toward them right so you want
to experience more or you you're not
even doing the the main thing that we're
prescribed to experience more
and it's like the example i gave in the
beginning you have this phone pick it up
um
you get a message whether that message
from allah whether it's from jinns
that's going to be dependent on which
form you did it did you do it through
prayer reflection
liquid stuff like this or did you do it
through a substance a psychedelic yes
and like i said if if it's making it to
where you can't put this phone down and
you think you think to yourself ah
i'm i'm gonna take this i'm gonna
experience more and you think that
you're picking this phone up and allah
is gonna be the one telling you all this
stuff to make you experience all that
stuff stuff for
a lot of people they don't allah
they're using these things as an escape
too bro like maybe they they might
actually not be let's say satisfied with
their job or spouse or some dunya thing
but that's what that's how pornography
addictions come that's how it puts you
in another world bro
it shows you another side of life where
you just can't wait till you just roll
that blunt again or watch that video
again because it takes you to another
dimension or just a false reality so i
want to mention in both those things i
want to start with your thing too first
bro when you're talking about you know
um
through prayer and stuff like that you
know the prophet muhammed rami please
tell us this he says that
if you've seen me in a dream know that
that's me
know that that's me okay cool how does
one see the prophet muhammed saw some in
their dream right i haven't i haven't
had the blessing has anyone ever seen
the prophet
tell us in the comment section below
like i want to know like has anyone ever
seen the prophet muhammad because i know
people have had experiences like that
and i would love to read i love reading
those stories but because i feel like
you're so lucky and fortunate
subhanallah to have seen something like
that he said if you've seen me know that
you've seen me because the shaitaan
cannot pose
everything like that okay cool
if you're on a substance there's no
guarantee that you can have any
recognition of if that's correct or not
right because when you are seeing the
prophet muhammad saw synonym right or
having a really spiritual effect how did
you get it like you said on him were you
praying were you meditating right i'm
gonna say something really crazy right
but like try to understand what i mean
by this right
when islam is practiced correctly it is
a drug
islam like i mean this is the most
respectful way possible it's crack
respectfully speaking don't cancel
skewer matter of fact cancel sq hashtag
let's get it trending okay i mean this
is the most respectful way because
there's something
intoxicating and intoxicating about your
sad when you need it bro when you need
it when you can only cry to allah and he
is the only one who understands your
pain there's something intoxicating
about that so you have not experienced
that drug you haven't experienced that
high that's where you're going to do the
shrooms and that's why you're trying to
smoke that blood because you haven't
experienced that i feel bad for you and
it's not because like you know we're
better than you it's not like that it's
because you have to give this a try with
an earnest heart you feel me and when
you start finding it bro naturally
oh you just stand for a longer time you
just stand for a longer time because
you're finding that comforting like ah
like yo this feels nice bro this feels
comforting this feels good it is
intoxication and find the comfort within
it check this out when the battle of oh
had happened okay and we know it was
devastating to the muslims devastating
right
bro the messenger of allah
had his teeth knocked out they thought
that he died they thought that he died
right it was bad it was so so bad and
you know and and subhanallah
talha radhiallahu and when they were in
the little trench trying to do that
right
would use his back and people would
climb out of the trench on dalhaz back
he gave the victory of that day of the
minor victories that we had to talk
allah
it's so special read i encourage
everyone myself us all to study the
battle of uh there's so many gems for us
to learn one biggest gem is this that
when you do not obey allah and this
messenger you will lose simple
you're lost already you've lost you
think you're winning by not obeying
allah and his messenger you've already
lost and the shaitaan has deceived you
okay so
the battle happens the greatest like
it's a bad time like muslims
died you know it's bad
okay
that time
couldn't have allah grown a little shrub
of your best kush you know think about
it everybody just enjoy this little tea
brew this
take the substance what did the
messenger of allah saw some do he prayed
he prayed he prostrated any little
moment he got he prostrated bro he
prayed to allah because he knew
that the comfort will only come in salah
so i'm asking myself you guys and
everyone listening out there why aren't
we finding the comfort in salah perhaps
we're not even doing it correctly what a
thought what a thought what if i'm
challenging all of us myself included
let's go and learn how to pray again
on your own not just from your parents
that teach you or may allah what your
teacher like go research a little bit
understand we talked about this in the
car right the attache
would say where did that come from did
you understand that that was a
conversation between the prophet saws
if you start thinking about it from then
you're literally
following the footsteps when when the
messenger of allah spoke to allah like
look i don't want to spoil it for you i
don't spoil it for anyone like bro fall
in love with you dean again
fall in love with it again what's taking
you so long fall in love with again is
this not enough motivating like isn't
this not enough that the fact that allah
wanted to hear this again like what else
do you need like okay you heard this
you're on the best podcast i had the
realest pockets in the dunya you already
know you already know what the zoms and
boys we out here we're doing some earth
sales as well to cop the merch what are
you doing what are you doing you think
you're gonna find goodness in marijuana
you're gonna find goodness and all these
things and believe me i'm not projecting
i'm not you know i've been through this
some of us have been through these
things guys we've come out of it for a
reason right and may allah protect us
and help everyone who's struggling with
it you said going back to your point
coping mechanism
we know you're doing it because
it's a cry for help it is really it's a
quiet for help smoking drinking any of
these things it's a cry for help you're
seeking help using these substances
try seeking the help of the one who's
made those things ask him for the help
you want knowledge you think a mushroom
will give you knowledge of the one who
made that mushroom who has the knowledge
that fungus
that trash
that garbage that grows it's garbage
it's fungus it's it's poop
it's garbage it's literally poop bro
you're getting knowledge from garbage
you're getting knowledge from
that people are the garbage like what
are you talking about
the one who's made it has all the
knowledge like allah you know and and
the messenger saw simon tell us about
this hadees remind us please about the
ring in the sand what was that hadith if
you remember recall about the knowledge
of allah like it's like he described the
the jannah it's like a ring that you
throw in the desert sand and it gets
lost are you familiar you want to talk
about slightly slightly someone tell us
in the comment section i know y'all
listening to this man allah's knowledge
is so vast it's like we have a draw
about that he has the ocean you give me
like
please remind us and you know correct us
what you're saying is why are you going
to the creation yes for knowledge and
spiritual enlightenment bro go to the
creator directly yes and if you don't
know and if you don't know what islam is
what should they do bro yes it's and you
know what it's it's the quran like you
said you quoted yasin right and think
about the word even yasin
we if you talk about knowledge right we
don't even know what yeah means
it's two letters
we don't even know what it what does it
unlock only allah has kept that and that
teaches us that no matter how much you
think you know you don't know you've
you don't know if you think you know you
don't know you know and what do you
think you think you're going to smoke a
little weed and then you're going to go
pray you're going to connect with allah
but brother it helps me shaytan is
deceiving you what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you sister you think
that that's gonna help you it's not it's
not and if you think that i could quit
any time if you could you would have
already cut it out acknowledge that you
have a problem acknowledge that
physiologically your body has become
addicted to it people who quit
try to go cold turkey bro they can't eat
they can't we're drunk
their stomach hurts bro for a week's
time they lose weight because they can't
eat now they can't even sleep they're
having real issues though their
physiological traumas that comes with
them bro their body's gone through
withdrawals they can't even sleep
anymore they've lost their peace i
thought that was supposed to help you
what's happening it's a drug stop
running away from these terms it was a
plant it's a drug yeah cocaine comes
from a plant too bro like you understand
like it's these are all plants that are
drugs it's something that's not meant
for our bodies you understand so like
people are going through withdrawals and
people that i could quit if i wanted to
yeah that's why
i just chose not to yeah
[Music]
let's just acknowledge it as well too
it's not easy if you try to quit on your
own but when you ask allah's help
you're trying to the problem is
we're trying to quit i try bro but i
keep relapsing because you're trying
tap into the real power ask
allah help your servant allah i'm
sincere oh allah help me help me quit
this allah make it disgusting to me
allah make it hate it to my heart allah
make me hate it allah make me disgusted
by this make me want to throw up when i
see this allah make me just i hate the
smell of it allah make it hate and allah
remove it from my bloodstream
remove this intoxication of the
physiology from my blessing allah purify
me oh allah allow your salah to
intoxicate me allah duas to intoxicate
me allow the athkar in your remembrance
and your thicker to the toxic be allah
remove it remove it remove it and have
you thought that perhaps allah will use
the substance of you quitting to help
you get closer to him yeah wow so you
went from sinning to allah not
converting that sin to a good deed for
you come on
is this not the most merciful is he not
the most merciful subhanallah
very jewish upon allah and um
uh it's funny this might seem a little
irrelevant but i'll tie into the points
he said that
music and quran cannot exist in the same
heart at the same time
so it means that if you're listening to
music you're replacing the quran but if
you listen to quran you'll be replacing
the music so when it comes to anything
that we use especially as a coping
mechanism you will find it very
difficult or impossible to remove it
unless you have something to replace it
because you still need to cope you
either need to deal with it you need to
cope with it and until you deal with it
you need to cope with it so if you've
been using that you need you need it's
not option you need to replace it i need
someone to quote brother romney in the
comment section below right now what he
just said right please just rewind this
and just just please quote him right now
mashallah bro because seriously you just
you smash it right now bro you said that
absolutely true absolutely
and and just to prove to the people
islam has all the answers when we were
talking i thought of a few ads from the
quran right in different places please
please that's so relevant so first and
foremost
allah says the verse that we all know
that indeed this life is temporary
delusional enjoyment it's not just
temporary it's temporary and it's
delusional enjoyment you think it's
something that's good right it's just
distracting you it's just a delusion
exactly like when you take these
substances and you just start to be
deluded and deluded and deluded and
seeing things you think you're on the
right path but you're not that's one of
the tricks of shaytan another one allah
says
he says those who believe and whose
hearts are content with the remnants of
allah he just reaffirms the same point
indeed with the remembrance of allah the
hearts find contentment and this try it
try it sit 20 minutes just 20 minutes
remove yourself remove everything and
everyone from the equation just think
about allah and then bring yourself into
the equation think about what allah has
done for you blessed you with right he
didn't have to give you a healthy body a
good family wealth living in a safe
place allah all these things think about
the things he gave you another verse
allah he says
he says
indeed these people he just says these
people they love the immediate they love
the in the moment and what is after that
behind them
a day that is grave a grave day the day
of judgment it's coming but they put it
behind them it's
they love the amusement right now
exactly they love that dopamine rush huh
you love that fast food sort of
connection you know what you said bro
about the music and the quran reference
right scientifically speaking right the
dopamine we we all and this is such a
big buzzword we've been talking about
people talk about dopamine fast and all
that sort of stuff and you should try it
i think that it's very very helpful
right so we know that people have this
misconception right that dopamine is the
production when you're listening to the
music dopamine was the production that
when you thought about listening to
music which caused you to listen to the
music because when you listen to the
music that level stops until it produces
some more dopamine till you find the
next trap which makes it more exciting
that's why people put it on shuffle
what's the next track gonna be and these
algorithms on spotify and apple music
they know you
they know what type of music they see
how quick you skipped it you could even
put a thumbs up thumbs down and all
these sort of things and they know how
to track you so they keep that dopamine
rush it's like a tick tock but for like
music and going back and forth back and
forth back forth okay now you have this
ex like extreme amount of dopamine rush
okay
how is the quran going from that to more
slow more calm and you know just more
subtle supposed to bring you that same
dopamine rush it won't you've messed up
your receptors right so that's when when
people are you they're opioid abusers
right and those are the people who are
into like pills and you know opioids
basically and their their receptors of
the opioids have been messed up right so
now the dopamine receptors are messed up
now the most basic tasks like going for
a walk in the park that does not
stimulate them anymore you know because
their dopamine receptors are so messed
up and it's use it's still getting
dopamine don't get me wrong but it's not
the same amount anymore so they're not
the same i remember a friend of mine uh
who's passed away who died through an
overdose think about that that's how you
die through a drug overdose right
non-muslim or anything like that scary
and there's muslims who are dying from
drugging over this dude don't get it
twisted these
epidemics of opioid abuse and all that
it's happening with venezuela and the um
unless we talk about it it's not going
to get healed it's not so put that a pen
for a side right
you know he was stuck on heroin
he was stuck on heroin so you know when
people try to get off these things
doctors and stuff like that they start
recommending marijuana medical marijuana
because they try to get you off of that
with something else right and look at
the difference of what a recommendation
is when are they recommending a medical
marijuana when a person is literally
like you know a heroin addict okay now
i'm not here talking about cancer users
in last stage i can't i'm not here to
talk about that but try to understand
where i'm going with this okay
bro he smoked and smoked and it did
nothing for him at all nothing while you
and i like if we were to go like two
poles oh my god like whoa like whoa whoa
oh tap out right he was able to smoke
and nothing was happening to him because
of his opioid receptors are completely
shot so now you listen to music right
which is a form of crack within itself
which is a form of a drug your opioid
receptors are already messed up okay now
try to go from music pause that now
listen to the quran
you went from boppin
um
okay
maybe let me let me get out of this
right why shaitaan is playing a role too
so we have the science explaining
certain things but it's the shaitaan
shaitaan wants you to stay away from the
remembrance of allah he wants that's his
goal that's his goal he does not want
you to remember allah and you're you're
you're you're you're you're sort of
feeding into his hand his hand is so
exposed you know when you play you know
cards are stuck for the love you're not
playing cards you know maybe mashallah
it's fun we should play unknown there's
a lot of fun right but shaitan is
playing with his cards up
shaytan's cards are up you know we know
he doesn't have a poker face right it's
hair like this is what i'm gonna do to
you right but the problem is shaitaan
doesn't come to you with a pitchfork and
red and horns
no he comes to you in the form of
suggestion of a friend
of peer pressure of uh homie like you
know like you know like you know like
why don't you try it you know he comes
in the form of people he comes in the
form of an idea of a suggestion of a you
know a what's wise a commercial a
commercial an advertisement you know it
comes in these forms and tempts you
again and again and again until you do
it so what do you do ask you what's the
what do i do oh allah help me o love
remove these sort of things oh allah you
know every time i think about doing some
type of sin like this allah i want to
remember you more i'm going to say la
illah
a hundred times shaitaan runs away he
forgets his way he doesn't even know
where he is he runs away from you and i
think about that are we doing that if
the answer is no no wonder he has a grip
on us
let's be honest let's be honest are we
doing our earth god it's a shield right
so are we doing the right things or not
you know i mean i may allah help us all
because we're all struggling at the end
and a lot of us we know what it is we
got to do bro we know what it is bro
definitely because we do it when we're
in such a low and allah helps us and
then we're like okay we don't need any
more me and were talking about this it
was it was about those people on that
ship that allah describes in the quran
that when things are like rocky you know
and tumultuous and turbulent they're
just like oh allah please please please
please please please help me
and then the ship calms down the waves
calm down the waves settle
and they're like oh allah didn't do that
that was gonna happen anyway
we don't need allah
when the plane is turbulent bro every
all the atheists are just like god
please please please and the plane calms
down they're like oh okay it wasn't god
i was gonna do that anyway it was just a
little turbulence you know
allah protect us from this you know and
i just want to be clear right you know a
person watching this they're listening
to this you know shout out to all you
guys out there um
honestly like you hear this and i don't
want you to think that this is a little
round table that no no pun intended this
is a round table okay a round table of a
bunch of muslims were just so pious
we got it together right oh look at you
brother what are you doing huh
we don't have it together i just want to
be clear over here right your struggle
might be marijuana my struggle might be
lowering my gaze let's just put it all
in perspective
you know that's the thing we all have
challenges we all have issues we all
have our own demons so to speak right
and we ask allah to help us because only
allah can exercise these demons from our
lives only allah can help us from this
so if we really really want the help of
allah we have to acknowledge acknowledge
where are we falling short do not
justify it don't look for a random fatwa
you know what i mean don't look for
random facts well who's going to say it
you know psilocybin right there's this
mufti on there
on the on youtube right
who says that yeah so simon is totally
fine
that should be that should be one of
your means you should definitely have
that's a funny one right but he you know
he would say that it's okay you know
because when you want to do it when
you're nuffs wants to do it you're going
to find a way to rationalize anything
don't look for the quran verse because
there's a lot of quran verses that you
should be looking for that turn that
should turn your heart back to allah you
know don't be selective because what's
the difference between you and that
islamophobe who only selectively looks
for verses of hatred in the quran you're
looking for selective verses to prove
your point of disobeying allah you're
looking for falsehoods that's not that's
not the way you need to do it you need
to acknowledge your mistakes acknowledge
your shortcomings and look okay like i'm
struggling with this i'm struggling with
smoking weed like that's just look
that's my weakness may allah help me i'm
struggling to lower my gaze that's my
weakness may allah help me i'm
struggling with pornography may allah
help me but it will only be helped when
you acknowledge it because once you
acknowledge it you also acknowledge a
stud for allah seeking allah's
forgiveness because you're acknowledging
that it is only allah who can forgive
you that's bro that is
that is
seeking allah's forgiveness is such a
huge act of worship it's huge huge huge
huge because you're acknowledging that
it is only allah who can forgive you of
that because you have to return to him
you're thinking of so many things
subconsciously you know so so seek
allah's forgiveness seek and say for
allah you heard this positive don't even
go further pause it right now make some
fresh wadu go pray two raka's to go pray
to arakas and ask allah forgiveness
pause it make a sajdah right now that
allah has helped you by giving you an
idea and and just seek his forgiveness
right now noah who needed no qibla
where's the qibla no just put your head
and sajdah and thank allah allah thank
you
you've shown me the way you've guided me
out the darkness
what else do you want yeah i mean like
what do you think you can get some
coupon
like no this is it this is it this is
how you're going to find out what you
should or shouldn't be doing so don't
over complicate it don't think that
you're going to get some other this was
your message the question is what are
you going to do about it yeah that's not
a lot very true very just upon allah and
i want to there was actually one more
verse please and it beautifully ties
into this but i'm going to save it for
last inshallah
that means you got to stay to the end
guys
don't move don't move
a little bit
so what i want to say now actually ties
into a point you mentioned before right
but before i get there actually i just
remembered another point actually
i would have been lost
i mean
when it comes to uh
yeah so when it comes to what you just
mentioned about practicing sam and
everything is found allah
these are little things that we can do
right but i think there's an overarching
thing which is your perspective and your
objective right if you have an overall
perspective
with islam with allah and you have an
overall objective of pleasing allah
these are all little things you do to
achieve the objective i want to please
allah therefore i will do good right
so
switch your objective your objective
what were you taught do whatever makes
you happy do whatever makes you feel
good that physical pleasure right and
you get it everywhere the tv your iphone
on tick tock is absent everywhere bro
you get that you don't get you might not
get the same feeling you know listen
watching this
maybe you do
but that's what you've been taught and
your objective subconsciously has been
let me please myself let me please
myself switch your objective let me
please allah switch your objective
everything else will change you know i
mentioned this
press the button right now press the
button we need a button pressed
something something give me a meme
oh i got you this is haram let's go that
was beautiful
so you got to switch that objective and
thoughts feelings and actions work in a
triangle
thoughts that's actually something we
learned back in high school fast
feelings actions work in a triangle so
if you do more good you will think more
good and feel better right if you think
good you will do more good and feel
better right and if you allow your
feelings to affect you then it will
affect your thoughts and your actions as
well so if you feel depressed sad the
most the best thing you could do is
maybe try and make someone else happy
you will feel better you will start
thinking better that's actually how it
works so allah has created us in a way
where if we do good we will think good
and feel good right and if we think good
as well we will do good and we will feel
good it works in a beautiful triangle so
that's why i say switch your objective
and switch your actions switch
everything we know the hadith process
where he said a man came to him he's
like
should i tie my camel or should i just
leave him trust allah will take care of
it what's the fastest say probably
something that man wasn't expecting if
he knew it he wouldn't have asked he
said tie your camel and then trust in
allah you got to do what you got to do
what allah commands you to do and then
trust allah that he will take care of
the rest of things that are out of your
control your healing it's never a linear
process it's not but trust allah will
take care of it now
i want to um
go back to a point you mentioned which
is related to this which is like we're
very kind of objective oriented if you
focus on one thing you will miss
everything out like if you're focused on
lost mata you almost
just test this there are videos i don't
know how they can test it without
knowing exactly what's happening but my
own anecdotal experience i saw this
video once
and it was a bunch of people on a white
t-shirt throwing like black balls or
something like that like little um uh
like what's it called
bouncy balls or like um stress balls or
whatever passing it back and forth right
and they're like i want you to count how
many times it's passed or it was a
basketball i don't know
and you're like one two three seven
eight i think it's eleven little do you
know a man in a gorilla suit walk
through them you never even notice it
yeah because you were so focused on
counting how many balls were being
tossed you didn't even see it the same
exact thing well when i saw that the guy
said you didn't see the girl i'm like
shut up man there's no girl i go back
i'll watch it now i'm looking for the
guerrilla because i'm focused on that i
don't know how many balls they threw but
i see the gorilla now because i'm
looking at it we are objective oriented
that's why i say make your objective
pleasing allah and the last thing i want
to say
inshallah the last thing i say for the
podcast is something allah asks in the
quran
very powerful allah he says
so where are you going
where are you going that's very powerful
where are we going you know where are
you going where are you going where are
you going where am i going
we don't know and allah what is saying
what is this after he says this is just
a reminder for mankind which is a
reminder do with it what you will
it's powerful no bro say that one more
time
which part i love
[Music]
where are you going right
where are you going we don't know allah
knows actually that's the best part we
don't know where are you going he says
this is just a reminder for mankind
how do we hit the hour mark already bro
what a boss statement to say right
look how allah just he just drops that's
a mic drop well that's honestly that's a
mic job and you know and same thing with
what we're doing look we could share all
these anecdotal experiences right and
you could feel how you want to feel what
you want right but do what you want with
these experiences right we're telling
you what it is and we're telling you how
it is right we're not here to modi
called to you about you know how it
should be how you want it to be it's not
how you want it to be it's going to be
how it is these things are dangerous and
if you don't want to believe us and you
want to try it out i can't stop you
we're not going to be you know when
you're about to do something you know uh
brother romney's not going to slap your
hand out of it you know like you're
about to do you know we're not going to
be around you but allah is going to be
watching you yeah allah is going to be
watching you and will i when you do
these things and if you heard this
podcast our voices are going to echo in
your head like like nah nah nah that's
crazy what's going on right now but
honestly
that was really powerful
and you know the best part i didn't make
it it was from allah from the quran
that's allah all you got to do is listen
to the quran all you got to do is read
the quran understand reflect on it allah
says in the quran as well in the book
itself do they not reflect upon the
quran and that's the biggest problem i
think people say
may allah unlock our hearts so that we
can reflect on the quran may allah
unlock our minds allah purify our hearts
so that we can come closer to him
because if we're not coming closer to
him it's because our hearts are not
purified and we have to purify our
hearts purify our intentions this piece
of flesh if this is good everything is
good and if this is corrupt everything
is corrupt so
purify it with the proper intention as
to why you want to do this allah i want
to get closer to you when you make the
dua of guidance it always gets accepted
always so make the dua of guidance of
your heart focus on your heart
oh allah the turner of hearts turn my
heart towards your obedience and your
guidance turn my heart towards you allah
allah will turn your heart of course who
else will who also respond to the call
of the desperate besides allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala
i mean
how did it hit an hour mark already bro
yeah it hasn't really brought away
sometimes we're talking and i'm just
like
i don't mean any offense to you guys
right i love talking to y'all yeah but
sometimes
sleep deprivation or like
me rami i know we got some food waiting
you know sometimes when it's one of
those when i'm done ones i'm just like
looking it's like 24 minutes 25 bro it's
already over an hour
and honestly i'm i i'm really grateful
to allah that he surrounded me around
really not only open-minded people but
also with someone with martial articles
knowledge such as yourself as too uh
brother army because you know we could
sit over here and make the most powerful
speeches and most powerful points and
you know powerful analogies but when you
recite the quran there's nothing higher
than that there's nothing more higher
than what he look like
mike dropped it with just two eyes of
the quran right that puts everything to
what we said to to bed you know what i
mean
so it's it's the quran that has the
power it's the quran that has the wisdom
it is it is you turning to allah that
will get it guys so and honestly don't
turn towards these substances and if
these things were supposed to help you
and people you know people have the
argument you know it helps me it helps
me it helps me if it was supposed to
help you why hasn't it helped you i
thought help means you get the help and
it's like you done i got the help right
or are you saying that it's crippling
you is it paralyzing you is it making
you handicapped is it making you
codependence on it right is that really
is that a crutch is it really helping
you is it right and and these things bro
when it comes to even look i i'm no one
shy people know me they understand like
you know i enjoy high fashion stuff like
that and it's not in my heart it's in my
hand i love it you know i like to have
it but it's whatever you know what i
mean but just remember something these
things need you you don't need it right
the marijuana
the weed the the the shrooms the these
psych they need you to be consumed you
don't need it you understand for it to
have its effect they need you to consume
it you understand
you don't need it don't think that you
need it you don't you know what you do
need you need allah
when
islam
was in the three darknesses the darkness
of the night the darkness of the ocean
the darkness of the belly of the whale
he didn't call out to allah
for the need of marijuana
these are messengers of god they had
revelation they know what is and what
isn't they know they know these plans
and these things and all that sort of
stuff right he called out to allah for
guidance and help
right
what was the dua that he made my brother
i might paraphrase a little bit
something along the lines of um
yeah allah forgive me i've been from
amongst all rights
right and when he heard that right and
when he was making the dua not just once
or he was just repeating that the angels
are saying we hear a voice that we've
never we it sounds familiar but where's
this coming from like it's it's coming
from a strange place
that was his servant eunice
okay he spits him out the whale okay he
comes out and there's the acid marks on
him his skin is burnt and all that sort
of stuff another perfect opportunity
give him the weed look another plant
allah grew another plant i just want to
be look i just want to clear the doubts
for the people right allah created
everyone's just like allah made that
plan is made by allah okay cool so that
plant allah grew a plant that he was
instructed to rub on him to take care of
his wounds and everything like that the
marijuana plant could have been grown
but that's not what allah grew because
that's not what he needed what he needed
was to call out to allah and that's what
he did and then the help will come from
allah you don't need these substances my
brothers and sisters you don't need
these things they need you it's just
that's what i mean by it they need you
you don't need it stop overempowering
these things you've made it you've given
it a wrong meaning and this goes back to
what you were saying right about the
story that we're telling it you're
giving it the wrong meaning that you
need it you need it oh i can no it needs
you change the meaning it needs you you
don't need it those nice sneakers those
high fashions it you don't need it it
needs you
it needs you to stand in the line apple
needs you to stand in the line the
jordans need you to stand in the line
right it needs you to go all crazy about
it and go for the black friday boxing
say a box day says it needs you
you don't need it's the marijuana for
you to go and buy it
it needs you you don't need it so
remember that change the meaning behind
it you know what you do need allah
when you put that in your mind that
allah i'm prioritizing the wrong things
allah allah you've made allah the option
and these things are priority swap it
around ask allah help you o allah help
me make you the priority allah help me
make your salah your obedience your
quran recitation learning about the
prophet muhammad if you engage in
learning the seed of the prophet
muhammad
i promise you in the story of the
messenger salsa in his example is an
example for everyone
in his example in his life there's an
example for everyone and for you and for
me everyone you just haven't found it
yet go go listen to the sita study sita
learn it there's so many options you're
running out of excuses
the excuses are finished my brother
sisters let's start learning learn to
replace that drug with something more
positive we spoke about this right you
don't quit something without starting
something else you don't stop without
starting so okay brother ask you okay
three muslims we want to like stop this
so what are you gonna start instead
start reciting the quran start the sera
series start learning a hadith start
memorizing the quran start learning
about the prophet muhammad saw someone
start learning a hadith start learning
about allah's attributes start learning
about allah's names start calling them
out by those names so stop one thing and
start something else but you need to
start and with your mind because guess
what if you stop weed or psychedelics or
whatever more than likely like weed and
stuff like that you're gonna start
something else without knowing it it
might be pornography it might be
something worse so come up with the plan
allah help me stop this and start
something more positive replace what you
lost with something better and ask allah
allah replace it with something better
oh allah
every time i desire this
and i restrain myself from it allah
reward me every second i'm staying away
from it for your sake ya allah you know
me if it wasn't for my fear of you ya
allah if it wasn't for my sincere
obedience to you allah i would want to
do it allah for every second i stay away
from it reward me allah wow
every second you're staying away from it
it's become an act of worship you
quitting smoking weed and disobedient
allah disobeying allah has become an act
of worship now subhanallah is crying
shaytaan is crying he's hating himself
right now how he tried to get you in it
and allah got you out and he blessed you
more
so ask allah ask allah's help and this
is not a message to you my brothers and
sisters this is the message to me to you
brothers as well too because you know
again we all have our own habits that we
will not be proud enough to say over
here and as we shouldn't you know that's
between allah and us like and we need to
keep it that way but we ask allah to
make it easy for us all
i mean
i mean
there is
two things that i wanted to highlight
here
please highlight three with that light
skin voice mushroom
please
please take it all
if anyone has come this far and you're
still thinking to yourself well okay
maybe i
you know maybe they're just talking from
uh their perspective their point of view
and you know maybe there is something in
it for me right
so the first point i wanted to highlight
is that
like brother fire said you know this is
unlearned or unearned wisdom
okay this is unearned wisdom meaning
that like like i said the telephone
you're picking up the telephone you're
getting all this stuff listen
you're receiving so much that by the
time that you
come out of this trip
you can't internalize anything that you
received
right and a year my past two years might
pass and and then you might internalize
maybe like one percent of what happened
but it's like
you could have not taken it and you
would have internalized that same one
percent maybe even more but you would
have done it in a way of that of which
was permissible yeah in a way that which
when you pick that phone up you know it
was like a wrestler
you know it's a lot on the other side no
it's it's not you're picking up the
phone and having no idea
what the hell is giving you these
answers right so that's
that's point number one that i want to
highlight and then point number two
is that if you're still not convinced
about this
well
i don't even know if we said this but
uh some people don't come back
some people take these things and
they're just awesome before bro before i
was even muslim like i i had my pops i
told you all before this but my pops
used to tell me like oh
um don't take these things because like
some people don't come back
some people don't come back sure and i
say this
not even
like i say this because i'm ashamed but
uh this
there's a part of me that actually has
never come back like i've lost like a
piece of my innocence
and like i feel like there's almost this
like animalistic side
there that's like i can't put it away i
can't like turn it off and
and um like you know how i talk to y'all
about martial arts all the time i talk
to you about being like super like aware
you talked about like my spatial
awareness my own sensory awareness it
never goes away bro yeah yeah no it that
not only that but like i have other
things that it's like situational
awareness situation awareness but like
it's almost like
a part of me is like always turned on
and that sounds weird no it's a
heightened sensitivity no but i'm saying
like um
it's like an animal list like you see an
animal and an animal is like always like
attuned to everything like trying to
survive and i have this part that's like
turned on now and i can't turn it off
subhanallah it's kinda like bro there's
so many people i know that that have
been through that predicament where it's
like forget like a part of their
identity but it's like it's like a
switch has been turned off or a switch
has been turned on whatever it would be
it could be mental
insanity it could be peace it could be
one society it could be intrusive
thoughts it could be hearing things
auditory hallucinations visual it could
be anything it's like once that happens
they can never get that back bro yeah
this is wallet this is the most scary
thing because a lot of people think okay
you drink you get a hangover two days
bro once you pass that branch of like
sensory overload
there is no coming back bro there's
water there's no like you will
permanently think you are broken yes
yeah that's how scary it is bro yeah it
was
what you just said bro you hit it on the
head for real and you know again i don't
want to you know elongate this a little
too much you guys watching at home
listen i'm sure you guys are enjoying
this marshmallow buttercup for real
because this i honestly honestly like
i'm not even just trying to like gas
this up
on youtube this is easily from a muslim
perspective the best podcast episode
when it comes to psychedelics marijuana
and this uses easily there's nothing
like this out there i personally believe
that that there's nothing like this out
there bro because what they heard what
they learned from this is you're not
going to hear this as from what i know
unless you know something link it
obviously in the comment section or
something i would love to hear it i'm
not trying to boast about it but it
because it came from the heart it's from
people with experience and knowledge
about this as well too and beautiful
beautiful versus the quran to back up
what we're actually talking about you
said you know you don't come back from
it right okay so so earlier we talked
about like you know people are using it
as a crutch that's exactly why people
are saying for medical uses they might
say psilocybin mushrooms might be good
for you right they said the people could
have traumas and all that sort of stuff
okay
um one one
you could actually when you take these
things right
uh
have go through a psychosis feeling
where you're actually hearing voices
this is a real fact like i've
experienced it you hear voices and when
it's off
maybe you relax and did i just hear
you say you don't come back fully did i
just hear a voice again and you start
actually going crazy because when you
went into that realm
you don't know what you brought back
with you right you understand
you don't know what you brought back
with you you went into that realm don't
think you came back alone you went into
a different dimension in a realm i'm
serious okay cool that's number one
number two let's suppose you're just
like oh no i'ma just take it whatever
it's fun oh you know i'm in college i'm
gonna do it for girls shrooms guys just
do some troops okay cool you might have
some traumas
within you locked away by allah's mercy
completely hidden locked from you some
trauma as a child that happened to you
that you were not even hip to because
allah saved you safeguard you you
experienced that trauma again you
relived it
in your bad trip that you're having and
you come out of it and you're scarred
you're back you're like oh my god what
is this what is happening and then your
life has been turned upside down and you
will never be the same again right again
i'm not trying to scare you and scar you
from this right because the flip side is
also true where people have had the
traumas and they've worked through their
stuff and all that and you're gonna
again attribute the shrooms you're gonna
attribute these things no
it was your risk going back to what
anhel said it was your risk that
knowledge was meant for you right but
did you go about the halawa or the way
allah was going to help you
get over that trauma anyways you just
relied on the substance instead of him
you just you get me you just rely on
something besides him i wanted to add on
to that to give some context because
maybe people wouldn't understand but you
just said it perfectly where some people
they might have some trauma but they
might have some trauma from the the
childhood or something like that like i
mean it's not a new thing i've said this
multiple times but in my childhood you
know i was abused as a kid
and that was very very rough for me like
i've gone through you know i don't say
this to get any sympathy or empathy or
anything like that it's just like it is
what it is i've been through it but when
i did the shroom remember how you said
people would do this stuff and it's like
oh wow like the grass feels so good like
look at the clouds like everything feels
so amazing like yeah for me i had that
and then it turned into
um
it's like i became an animal in the trip
and when i became an animal in this trip
it sounds weird it sounds like a video
game or something but i would look at
people and it's like i could see like
like the vein like just
posting but i could see like
certain movement patterns this is
hallucination this is psychosis yeah if
you told someone that you weren't on a
substance you were experiencing this you
went and told a medical professional
they would admit you into a hospital and
they would get you addicted on other
drugs like xanax think about this think
about what you're just saying right now
think about what you just said right now
i go out and i see and i can becoming an
animal and have gills and have all these
things
they would say that this person needs
some help and let's admit him for three
days inside the psych ward it was for
real nah but listen listen i i would see
like these i would see like i was with
my friends that i remember i was looking
at them and i could see their vein right
here like pulsing like every pulse of
the heartbeat i would see it
and then with that i could almost see it
i it's so crazy but i could see the
glands on their face
like changing sizes like
changing bigger and then going smaller
but i could feel like the energy whether
they were closed off whether they were
open from the voice from the movement
like everything and then
from there i started seeing their
strengths their weaknesses and all this
stuff and it's like i
that's never left so you have a hyper
awareness yeah to this point nowadays
when i'm like if i'm with everyone like
y'all right now or when i'm in a public
setting like i have to literally
that when i when i start thinking about
this i have to like put it aside and
just like keep myself in the present
that's why you were looking at my neck
when you got me from the airport i see
you
[Music]
you never come back the same and again
like we said when you go in there you
never know what to come bringing back
with you and you never know how you're
going to come back from it you know
people want to make it seem like you
come back enlightened or something like
that no not necessarily not like that
you know and again any wisdom that you
are getting that was your risk that you
were going to get from allah you could
have gotten that by reading you know a
book from imam shafi you know i mean you
could have gotten that wisdom from
written like reading something of more
value that was your risk to get but
you're taking
a huge risk you know
by even trying these substances so i
guess i look guys final words right
final words it's this is something scary
alhamdulillah
save this and may allah safeguard the
ummah everyone listening as well too and
obviously us as well and may
may allah help all those who are
struggling with this with this disease
with this harm with this addiction with
this intoxication allah you know we only
worship you allah we only call to you
allah and we know allah it is you it is
you allah who can safeguard us and help
us allah we ask you allah and we know
that you respond to us all uh when we
ask you for guidance allah please guide
us and help us as well too
i mean
and with that being said oh wait
[Music]
we foreign let you start it off
all right
we better catch you
oh not responding back it's for the
crowd it's for the audience mashallah
do you want to do the full intro
listen here with the with the three
muscles
come on what is the full intro you know
bro listen if you if you're a real t3m
fan member you know what the real
interesting point it's it's
gonna float again i've only watched like
a snippet of y'all's videos
we're back here with uh the most
handsome 22 year old ah the most
beautiful looking bangladeshi i think
listen i think you guys did you see that
kardashian bangladeshi and then you guys
ready you guys open it you guys open it
there's an opening bro we're gonna keep
it rolling is gonna keep it going don't
don't crop it
this is
[Music]
hello
[Music]